lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
tratar de calcular a que es igual x a la
cuarta menos 2 x a la tercera más 5 x
dividido entre x pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo por su cuenta antes
de que lo resolvamos juntos muy bien si
decimos que es igual esta expresión de
arriba dividida entre la expresión de
abajo otra forma de pensar en esto es
porque tengo que multiplicar esto que
pongo entre paréntesis aquí sí
multiplico esto por x debemos tener que
es igual a x a la cuarta menos 2 x a la
tercera más 5 x como hacemos esto hay
dos formas en las que podemos resolver
esto una es reescribir esta expresión y
voy a poner esta x en amarillo para que
no se nos pierda podemos escribir esto
como 1 / x x x a la cuarta menos 2 x a
la tercera más 5x y luego distribuimos
este 1 entre x en cada término a que va
a ser igual esto va a ser igual a x a la
cuarta entre x menos 2x
será entre x + 5 x entre x a que serán
iguales estos términos x a la cuarta
entre x es como si tuviera 4 x
multiplicadas juntas y luego las dividió
entre x va a ser equivalente a x a la
tercera potencia esto de aquí es x a la
tercera también podemos llegar a esto
usando las propiedades de los exponentes
en el denominador tenemos x a la primera
potencia por lo que restamos los
exponentes al tener la misma base
esto es x a la tercera y ahora a que es
igual esta parte de aquí es menos 2 x x
a la tercera entre x a la primera y por
la misma propiedad va a ser igual a x al
cuadrado y por último pero no menos
importante tenemos 5x y lo dividimos
entre x va a ser igual a 5 podemos
verificar que esto x x va a ser igual a
x a la cuarta menos 2 x a la tercera más
5 x vamos a hacerlo ponemos x al cubo
menos 2 x al cuadrado más 5 x x
distribuimos la equis y nos queda x por
equis a la tercera es igual a equis a la
cuarta equis por menos 2x al cuadrado es
menos 2x a la tercera y x x 55 x al
principio mencioné que había dos formas
de resolver esto la segunda forma es
analizar el numerador y tratar de
factorizar la equis es decir que trató
de factorizar lo que sea que esté en el
denominador vamos a hacer esto y vamos a
reescribir el numerador x a la cuarta la
escribimos como x por x a la tercera
reescribimos el menos 2x a la tercera
como más x x menos 2 al cuadrado y luego
podemos escribir este 5x como x por 5 y
luego voy a dividir todo entre x
simplemente reescribir el numerador
factor izando una x para cada uno de los
términos y ahora factor izamos la x de
todo esto el quitar la x de cada término
es hacer lo opuesto a la propiedad
distributiva si factor hizo esta x de
cada término que quedara pues queda x x
x a la tercera
- 2 x al cuadrado más 5
terminé escribiendo usando el mismo
color pero espero que esto no los
confunda a ustedes y todo esto se divide
entre x y siempre que x sea diferente de
0 x entre x va a ser igual a 1 por lo
que queda la respuesta que obtuvimos con
el método anterior estas son dos
aproximaciones diferentes no hay nada
sofisticado aquí al dividir entre x
podemos decir que multiplicamos cada
término por uno entre x o podemos
factorizar la x del numerador y luego
cancelarla con el denominador